[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, everyone.
We're now at the Web
Sandbox and we're
going to talk to Paul
about Lighthouse.
Now you may remember, Lighthouse
gives you actionable advice
for improving your websites.
Paul, come on over here and
show us what this is all about.
PAUL KINLAN: How you doing?
Yeah, so this is our Lighthouse,
real world lighthouse
that we've got as well.
So Lighthouse is our tool that
helps developers actually fix
the problems on their sites.
So we open up Chrome,
run Data Tools,
and then we just inspect a whole
bunch of the tools that we've
got or the problems on the
page and give developers
actionable advice.
But the problem that
we've got is that we've
got a lot of different tools.
So this is our
actual central place
to try and unify
Google's performance,
informational, architectural
tooling story as well.
So should we give it a demo?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Yeah, let's do that.
PAUL KINLAN: All right, cool.
So here we go.
I'll use my site because
it's probably the best
and I like people
to go to my site.
So what happens, we're
going to enter the URL.
And so basically,
developers at the event
are going to be able to come up,
put their URL in, and then get
actual real world feedback
about how to improve their site.
So we can press Go
and it goes off.
It runs Lighthouse, it runs
PageSpeed and also WebPageTest.
And we've also got a number
of other different tools
as well, which we're not
automating today because it's
a little bit too much.
But we want to give developers
an idea of what's happening.
So the first one's already come
through, the page [INAUDIBLE]
inside score.
So the general
mobileness is good.
I'm 99 out of 100.
And then the Lighthouse scores
have also come through as well.
So I'm doing well in
performance, progressive web
app-ness, I'm not doing
very well in accessibility,
I need to fix that, and my
SEO is pretty poor as well.
Then if you want a
little bit more detail,
we've got the View
Report button as well,
which will give you a full
detailed report that you
can go and send
back to your manager
and tell them like, everyone's
just seen how poor our site is.
Let's go and fix it.
Or how good it is, actually,
and give me a raise.
So yeah, that's our
Lighthouse, our PageSpeed.
We've got a numerous
range of different tools,
and this whole area
is about trying
to show you what goes where
and how to use it and when.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is awesome, Paul.
And I have to admit, I
was kind of expecting 100s
across the board.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I know
Dion said the same as well,
and he's going to have
words with me later on.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you
so much for showing this.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank
you very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, if
you want to see more videos
just like this, remember to
head on over to g.co/io/guide.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'll see you in the next one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]